with the move to alert level two council
super centers are now open again many of
our services can be accessed remotely so
you may want to try contacting us by
email phone or Facebook before coming in
we'll be taking a few precautions to
ensure the safety of both customers and
staff if you just need to drop something
off there will be a box provided at the
door entry and exit points will be
separated so please follow the signage
and staff instructions you may be asked
to wait before entering the building and
we'll ask you for your name your number
and email address for contact tracing if
required with push and floor markings to
help you maintain physical distancing if
you need to queue we've also installed
perspex screens at the counter we
regularly cleaning surfaces and
equipment and hence sanitizer is
available because our normal interview
rooms are quite small meetings with
staff will take place elsewhere in the
building but your conversations will
remain private if you are unwell please
stay home until you have recovered
Infernus if you are concerned about
missing a payment or a deadline to talk
to our staff from the building unit or
the duty planner you need to make an
appointment if you have any concerns or
questions please talk to our team we're
happy to help